widowed by the 9 11 attacks
former member of the last man battalion
former joint task force head of
department
conspiracy theorist genius tech
entrepreneur
why was this anti-government anti-shd
civilian so important to the success of
the division's mission
in new york city
born and raised in central jersey he
attended rutgers university
and was later involved in a number of
tech startups
a highly anxious and cynical individual
rhodes was the type of person who never
liked to dwell in any place for too long
he felt like an outsider wherever he
went and could never find a good enough
reason to stay
it's a surprise that he managed to stay
in manhattan long enough to meet his
wife
perhaps she pretended not to be
interested and rhodes who isn't afraid
to knuckle down when the going gets
tough
was intrigued unfortunately
not long after they wed the 9 11 attacks
occurred
and she was one of the people killed in
the world trade center north tower
collapse
utterly devastated road sought revenge
against the terrorists he was furious at
the us government's response
and because of this rather than joining
the u.s armed forces
he joined a private military company
called the last man battalion
in 2003 the lmb was stationed in iraq
and rhodes was serving his time as an
engineering contractor
not long after they were stationed his
team was ambushed
and the attack left him as the sole
survivor of his unit
overcome with feelings of guilt he was
constantly questioning why he had
escaped death
while others had lost their lives again
and again
he wondered whether it was something he
could have done to prevent the ambush or
in some way that he could have saved the
others lives
eventually the strain of survivor's
guilt proved too much
even for him and rhodes left iraq and
the lnb
returning to manhattan this event
paired with losing his wife meant that
rhodes does the utmost to avoid any kind
of intimate relationships with others
he has a lingering distrust of most
government agencies including the
division
and his time working with the last man
battalion has only further enhanced his
skeptical
and blunt outlook according to the
division's personnel
vials rhodes is considered to be
incredibly intelligent
a tech genius and an expert weapons
engineer
above all else he places the highest of
value on an individual's capability on
doing what is right
for the greater good
after the dollar flu outbreak rhodes
offered his services to the joint task
force
in new york he quickly rose through the
ranks to become the chief engineer
after a power outage in the jtf base of
operations
rhodes traced the fault back to a
generator failure in the subway morgue
while leading a team down to fix the
fault the jtf suddenly lost contact with
them
second wave division agents staged a
rescue mission
in turn allowing him to restore power to
the base of operations
later an lmb member and a friend of his
from way back when they worked together
decided to defect from the private
military company stating that he didn't
support the direction that they were
heading
so rhodes sent in a small jtf team to
extract him in exchange for l b
intel unfortunately the lmb found out
they sent a squad to kill rhodes team
and the traitor
reluctantly rhodes asked the division to
assist him in rescuing his friend
they were successful and managed to
deliver the lmb deserter to a jtf squad
who are waiting to take him back
to the base of operations
throughout the activities early on in
the outbreak rhodes continued to provide
expert advice
and advanced technical solutions towards
everything that the hostile factions
were able to throat them
i can't do this [ __ ] anymore it's
probably just a power outage
the network going down and you get in
orders to go to dc
which you ignored by the way is not just
a power outage
we all got the call it was probably just
a glitch in the system
i'm needed here you're not needed
anywhere
paul you know i don't trust the division
i can't
between keener and first wave [ __ ]
the network [ __ ] isaac
constant reminders that director 51 was
a terrible idea gone too far
so what do you want to do rhodes i want
you to stop
justifying the [ __ ] law and take
some goddamn responsibility
the months following the activation of
directive 51 saw poor decision
after poor decision including badly
planned quarantine zones
and then the portrayal of countless
numbers of division agents
rhodes needed people he could trust and
the division were not it
he needed out we need to talk
that's never good you're gonna need to
find a new lackey
you leaving rose benitez already told
you
he gave me a heads up he trusts me
i know it's been hard for you here you
haven't been happy for a long time
i've never been happy at least you're
honest you need me to train my
replacement or something we'll manage
go ahead you quit on us a long time ago
help
out your new settlement maybe you'll
find whatever it is you're looking for
whatever well
rhodes left the joint task force and the
base of operations
he went on to assist a number of
civilian settlements with their
preparations
and defenses eventually he established
his own settlement with a number of
former jtf
who had also had enough of the bad calls
coming from above
this settlement was called haven and was
located in southern manhattan
he would make sure that the community's
needs would be placed first
any outside help would be avoided if
possible he wasn't going to take any
chances with the care of the people
who looked to him for safety
hey agent rhodes is that you the hell
are you doing down here
finding a new way okay you gonna let me
in
sorry sorry you're not welcome here
oh come on rhodes these people count on
me to keep them safe
and i've seen you in the field i can't
let you in
have it your way roads you'll be sorry
i'm not here to protect you when rikers
come knocking on your door
okay take care now we'll handle the
rikers on our own thank you
however when the new york city hall was
attacked by the infamous rogue agent
aaron kina
it resulted in massive casualties to the
jtf and the division forces stationed
there
and although rhodes had a deep mistrust
of these agencies and had witnessed time
and time again the destruction that the
division agents brought along with them
he began to realize that the attacks
were inevitably getting closer and
closer to his new home
[ __ ] that the division had its chance we
need somewhere to regroup
find somewhere else how do you know
haven isn't keener's next target
are you kidding me you make us a target
we can keep you safe of course you can
just like hell's kitchen i'm not gonna
fall for that [ __ ] again
we're fighting this same fight here
you know what
our situation's a [ __ ] ton better than
ever was back in midtown
these people feel safe
you're right the situation
feels better for you now but feeling
safe
doesn't mean you are safe it's getting
pretty rough out deadpool
but it's your decision
do what you need to take care of keener
and then i want you out
all of you
so reluctantly rhodes allowed feylau and
the division to use haven as a forward
operating base in the hunt for aramkina
unsurprisingly he certainly didn't hold
back in expressing his distrust of them
and the superiors
he continued to help the division
throughout the southern manhattan
manhunt
in an attempt to have him leave haven as
soon as possible
after the division had caught up with
kina and eliminated him
it was discovered that feylau had gone
rogue and was working for the black tusk
rhodes had never trusted her and even
from early on they clashed
in his eyes this was the final nail in
the coffin for the division
though he appreciated what the division
had accomplished along with saving haven
in the process
his trust in the division would never be
restored
ever since the loss of his wife in the 9
11 attacks
rhodes has had a strong sense of disdain
for the government
so when he began to see the division
starting to fall apart with agents going
rogue
and his relationship with feylau going
from bad to worse
it's no surprise that he wanted to get
as far away as possible from it
[Music]
however with the virus rampant wards
raging across new york city
and the rest of the united states it was
only so long before haven would come
under threat
and rhodes would need to take action the
division needed his help
and he needed them too
rhodes is infused with a strong sense of
doing what is right
even when it comes to working with
others he mistrusts
and for this reason he's always been
there to assist the division
his intelligence ability with technology
and weapons
means that he's an invaluable source to
have at their disposal
and whom without the division would have
struggled to complete what they've
achieved so far
i hope you've enjoyed this thank you
very much for watching and i'll catch
you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Music]